[Music]
hello well welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where my brother John and I and
see a questions give you a dubious
advise and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you
doing John I'm ill I'm unwell Hank I was
I was unwell last week in this week of
it my cold is settled into my into my
chest for a small amount of what appears
to be bronchitis I'm just not I'm not
feeling I'm not feeling great but I'm
excited you know it always lifts my
spirits to be able to podcast with you
oh good oh good I have I have an update
for you John great last week we
discussed the peculiarity and and
potential disgustingness of putting
water on cereal yes and I went to my
house got my frosted mini-wheats out put
some water on it and ate him and do you
want to know how I felt about it John I
do was it delicious it was awful it was
so bad oh that's disappointing it's just
not a good idea
I mean why he really didn't like it with
water No so the thing is like yeah it's
it it's milk is sweet milk has a
sweetness especially the milk I drink
which is almond milk and and I've gotten
used to that over you know my entire
life and when you put a thing that is
not sweet it has no sugar onto your
cereal it just tastes it tastes almost
bitter and but but but more than that
more than anything it tastes empty like
there's just no like there there's no
richness to the flavor I encourage other
people to try it because maybe you will
feel differently than I do and then you
can have a lower calorie less impactful
breakfast meal but it's not gonna happen
for me John that's disappointing Hank
because I just I stand by my original
argument that cereal with water is a
healthy and delicious solution to the
how to moisten my cereal problem right
and and who knows maybe if everybody
used water on their cereal all the word
olds problems would be solved John maybe
Hank would you like me to read you a
poem about death that sounds like the
kind of thing that you do this poem is
by WH Auden I've been thinking a lot
about Memoriam poems like poems written
in memoriam a memorial took to other
people just because they've been so
there's been so much death it's January
still actually it's not it's February
deadly now it's the least deadly month
yep January the deadliest month for
humans February the least deadly month
but only because it has so few days
anyway this is a great great poem by WH
Auden I apologize in advance for not
being shorter but it's still fairly
short stop all the clocks cut off the
telephone prevent the dog from barking
with a juicy bone silenced the pianos
and with muffled drum bring out the
coffin let the mourners come let
aeroplanes circle moaning overhead
scribbling on the sky the message he is
dead
put crape bows around the white necks of
the public doves let the traffic
policemen wear black cotton gloves
he was my north my south my east and
west my working week and my Sunday rest
my noon my midnight my talk my song
I thought that love would last forever I
was wrong the stars are not wanted now
put out everyone pack up the moon and
dismantle the Sun pour away the ocean
and sweep up the wood for nothing now
can ever come to any good WH Auden with
the poem often known as stop all the
clocks cut off the telephone thanks for
bringing us up here John glad to god to
start the podcast off on the upbeat note
yeah it's no it's it's I was wrong about
the title it's uh it's actually called
funeral blues I really like I really
like that poem though it is a little
dark as I was reading it I realized that
it's okay it's a little bit sad I did I
felt uh I felt the sadness it was in me
it's still there indeed you know what I
like about that poem though Hank just
just real briefly what I loved about it
is that when people die when you when
people you love die one of the things
that I'm always struck by is that the
world goes on
so I remember like when we were burying
our grandfather our father's father I
remember looking out at the street and
just seeing all of the cars moving and
thinking well that's very strange that
the world is going on as if nothing has
happened and that WH Auden poem like for
me is that is that like clarion call of
like this is what death should be but of
course like can never be because because
it's something that people do every day
anyway sorry to start on a dark note
let's move on to questions from our
listeners uh before we get to questions
from our listeners I have an idea that
we should revisit a question we brought
up a couple podcasts back which is
whether or not like how much oil could
have been saved if we made DVD cases
yeah the appropriate size for fitting a
DVD inside of and not the size that
looks on in the shape of a book or VHS
tape this rectangular shape that is
completely arbitrary we had two people
write in after having done significant
research and/or math to determine how
much oil in fact we use we had a
response from Alex who did this all with
math and alex says that there have been
approximately 24 million barrels of
extra oil mostly but though equivalent
most of it is most plastic as apparently
made with natural gas I didn't know that
to produce the excess plastic in DVD
cases since the inception of DVDs and
now of course that's it's a very round
number but that is that's the the you
know just sort of like back of the
napkin calculation that is a huge amount
of oil John or equivalent oil that is a
very large amount of oil and then Aaron
did a different set of calculation and
he came up with 200 million kilograms of
oil which is just under 1.5 million
barrels
regardless it's an extremely large
amount of oil that was used to produce
the excess plastic and DVD cases and I
do have to think that when future
generations look back upon us the thing
that they will be most
baffled by is our inefficient use of
resources and whenever anyone points to
me you know some econ 101 model of
supply and demand I always want to reply
by saying that like you know look at the
massive massive inefficiencies in our
existing economy of goods and services
it's just absolutely astonishing when
you pause to think of it but yeah I'm
sure that we will be remembered for
having produced so much unnecessary
plastic millions of barrels of oil that
took hundreds of millions of years to
make and we just used them to make DVD
cases look like VHS tapes I'm curious if
you want to know the reason why Erin and
Alex's numbers are so different and also
why Erin in his response said that it's
possible that we in fact have wasted no
plastic I am fascinated to know the
answer to those questions it is because
when you are making plastic from natural
gas there are you are not just making
plastic for for DVD cases you are making
a bunch of different things and all of
those things have different uses there's
different kinds of plastic that get made
there's also different byproducts that
get used in other industrial processes
there's just a ton of different things
that get so it's basically like thinking
about instead of thinking about like
this is a barrel of oil a hundred
percent of it is gonna be turned into
plastic that's not how it ends up
working because of chemistry it's like a
cow where you have a cow and some of its
gonna be ground beef and some of its
gonna be liver and some of its gonna be
bone meal and some of its gonna be
steaks and all those different parts are
gonna have different prices based on
different markets and basically what
what Erin is saying is according to a
person that he talked to that works in
this industry his name was Chris that
this plastic was kind of going to be
produced anyway because all the other
things that that that were you know
necessary bought of the the byproducts
of this natural gas we're going to be
bought anyway so it's very like it's
another way in which like Wow sudden
the world is so much more complicated
than it seemed Aaron also adds that
there's a huge number of complexities
like the plastic wrap that goes around
the DVDs which is not technically
necessary there's like the fact that
DVDs sometimes are sleeved in cardboard
for no reason other than product
marketing it's and it turns out to be
very complicated also the big difference
where those two numbers are so different
is that Alex basically said every barrel
of oil that was involved in the creation
of the plastic whereas Aaron only
focused on the fraction that ended up
becoming the plastic Hank as you know
people come to our podcast largely to
learn about plastic I'm like giddy it's
like I think it's so fast they come here
learn about plastic and to hear
incredibly depressing poems about that
and here we are already having delivered
I mean and we've still got most of the
podcast ten minutes you could turn it
off now everything you ever wanted out
of a comedy podcast has been delivered
here on to your Hank and John that was
one of the funniest summaries of the use
of plastic and DVD cases I have ever
heard in my entire life
I for one feel that I have gotten an ab
workout just from laughing okay now you
can ask a question our first question
comes from Richard who asks Dear John
and Hank I have at the time of writing
336 subscribers on YouTube I'm happy and
grateful for all the people that make up
that number but I often find myself
daydreaming about all the things I would
do if I had more than two million
subscribers like you guys so here's my
question what would you do if in a
Freaky Friday style body swap you woke
up and you only had 336 subscribers on
YouTube would you still make the same
kind of videos I think first of all in
that situation my first concern would be
my children and my spouse why I would be
like why am I in another person right I
see what you and Who am I now married to
and where are my children and are they
safe or did they also experience a body
swap scenario yes that that is true I
think maybe you want to think of it as
not a
body swap but simply a channel swap
simply but I do like I want it like get
to the mechanics of this because I want
to figure out how the script of this
movie will be written because I do want
to watch it
but I feel like that's not Richard's
question and we should focus on that and
I don't I think it's so fascinating to
think about because my life is so
certainly my professional life is so
focused on the existing audience that I
have and that we have that and that
community that we have and like the that
they are the reason why I push myself to
make stuff why I you know like never
don't do it and why you know and like
knowing that there's that audience there
drives me to make something that's not
that's like that's accurate as possible
like I'm putting this out into the world
I'm affecting the world and I need to be
responsible about that and so like I'm
just so like affected by this in so many
ways that that trying to put myself into
a world where let's say everything else
is the same but I just don't have as
many YouTube subscribers but I'm still
making content I still AM like I'm still
a youtuber and like they still care a
lot about this I think that I would
probably make similar stuff but I don't
think that I would be able to work as
hard on it as I do I think that it's it
that like the reason I work so hard on
YouTube videos is because the audience
is there I would not make similar stuff
I mean I think that you know we had 200
subscribers or a little less than 200
subscribers after our first 100 YouTube
videos
back in 2007 mm-hm and I think I would
have finished the year I do not think I
would have continued after that year I
think that it would have been like a
cool experiment and I would have been
really psyched about all the neat stuff
that we'd done together and how much it
had brought us closer as brothers and I
think I might have continued in fact we
sort of did that even with the 9000
subscribers we ended up having at the
end of 2007 we slowed way down we went
to a point where we were only making you
know I
make a video one week you would make a
video the next week almost and we did
not have a schedule and I think that it
would have kind of continued down that
path until we were making videos very
very occasion right right I think you
probably would have made more because
you were always more invested in making
videos part of making videos and I was
always more invested in the the audience
part of making videos I mean I've never
been a good video editor I've never been
a particularly good youtuber so I think
I would have stopped and in general like
it's very hard for me to make stuff
absent if I don't have an audience or
the hope of an audience it's very hard
for me to make stuff right the other
thing I would say like that what you
said just now made me think a different
thing about my answer which is that like
I would be making different kinds of
content and it would be more focused on
at the audience that was there it would
certainly be influenced by the audience
that was there and back when we had a
smaller audience there was more of a
feel that that you know not just because
it was smaller also because it was early
days of YouTube and people were really
excited about it but the fact that it
was smaller made it easier for there to
be a stronger community and I think that
that would be like I would still be
focusing on that yeah
and you know and and like still also
focusing on growing that audience but
but having I was just thinking today
while I was shuffling my sidewalk free
of all of the white stuff that falls out
of the sky and about how like there was
a moment in 2007 when like suddenly and
I've never said this publicly before
there was like a week in 2007 when
suddenly I realized what we were doing
was like bigger than just like people
like me making content for other people
and then making content for me and
everybody's sort of on the same playing
field when I got like four different
phone calls from people who said did you
know your phone numbers in the phone
book yeah because like freaky people
could call you and I was like of course
my phone was in the phone book I'm a
person right like that's what the phone
books for it's a book full of people's
phone numbers but but there were like
but something had changed in enough
people's minds that a bunch of people a
seemingly independent of each other
looked me up in the phone book
were shocked to find that I would be
publicly listed and and and that was a
that was a thing that happened I mean I
remember that week because it was the
weirdest Freaky Friday estreet of my
whole life like I I mean I I remember
that vividly where all of a sudden it
felt like it went from this very
personal project with a small group of
extremely you know the kind of like
tight-knit audience members yeah
essentially Co participants in the
project to us making something for a big
audience right and and it was
interesting because I think our content
got way better like in terms of being
appealing to a broad audience
immediately it was almost like the new
audience inspired us to think about
making videos differently but it also
got in terms of it being but it yeah it
just changed dramatically and I remember
that week more vividly than I really
almost any week of my life because it
just felt like this massive sort of
somewhat terrifying wave cresting over
us alright I got another one this one's
from Emma Grace who asks dear Hank and
John the other day I found a box of mac
and cheese in the back of my pantry it
looked and seemed just about the same as
any other box of Walmart brand mac and
cheese I've had but it had been expired
for about a year since it was just
powdered cheese and noodles I ate it
anyway but many of my friends have since
told me that I'm going to die am I going
to die thanks I mean you're not going to
die but you have made a terrible
terrible mistake I disagree with John
and so does science no I don't care what
science says they put that they put that
they put that date there on a rather for
a reason I feel anxious Emma just just
from the overall situation you should
not eat out-of-date mac and cheese you
should not eat mac and cheese that you
have cooked and left in the fridge for
more than a week because that is problem
but when the what you're concerned about
is bacterial growth
and this is not going to happen in dry
macaroni and cheese it's what what will
happen is that the ingredients will
oxidize they will taste less good so
there will be things in there that that
were once one chemical that will have
become other chemicals both of those
chemicals are safe to eat but but one of
them might not taste as good as the
other so you are going to lose some
flavor that's what on dry goods the sell
by date is usually about same with the
same with sodas so does have a sell by
date but but there's not they're not
going to become unsterile on the inside
they are going to become less tasty and
that's that's what you want to watch out
for what you want to watch out for in
terms of health is is anything we're a
backward bacteria you could grow which
seems extremely unlikely inside of
powdered macaroni and cheese the emigres
so I want to emphasize that hank is
wrong and that you should not eat
out-of-date macaroni and cheese no
matter how confident he sounds in his
science he talked all right this is such
a great comedy podcast Hank I just I
can't tell you when I look at the iTunes
Comedy topless I just think like of them
we are the funniest absolutely we got a
question from G John who says dear Hank
and John my cat is asleep on my stomach
and I'm late for work however I don't
want to move because he looks so
comfortable plus it is the known rule of
cat owners that if the majestic animal
decided to name you its bed for a period
of time you lay there and enjoy it
however I am still late for work does
this count as a valid excuse for my
tardiness no but in a just world it
would I mean I think this might be the
difference between people who have a
deep underlying affection for cats and
people who don't understand why we chose
to domesticate that animal yeah I have a
deep underlying affection for cats and I
totally totally sympathize with you gee
this happens to me all the time
sometimes I'll be laying in bed and I
will have to pee really bad and then the
cat will come and lay on my bladder and
I'm like okay I'll just lay here with
you just stop moving okay but you just
lay there that's what you got to do
however
so weird I can't even tell you from the
outside how weird that seems I thought
that seems weirder to me then me eating
my cereal with water probably seems to
you I can't imagine that that's the case
but I will trust you
yeah I think you need to try it with
Raisin Bran I think that might be the
issue I think that maybe you need to do
it with like a good priests wheat and
cereal like Rays maybe the next time I
we do a patreon livestream which we did
before recording this this one we did a
livestream with our patreon patrons at
patreon coms last year Hank and John I
will have that patreon livestream while
eating raisin bran with water mmm God
that just sounds delicious what I
wouldn't give for some watered-down
Raisin Bran right now today's podcast is
brought to you by watered-down Raisin
Bran watered-down Raisin Bran John's
number one way to eat raisin bran this
podcast is also brought to you by the
complexities of the production of
plastics the complexities of productions
of plastics making life better for
everyone through science and today's
podcast is also brought to you by
expired macaroni expired macaroni I
don't care what science says throw it
away and today's podcast is brought to
you of course as always by dubious
advice dubious advice the specialty of a
couple of guys who are obsessed with
death and not being funny
don't forget our advice is dubious I
just don't want it I don't want to get
in trouble for dispensing such terrible
advice I think we have another question
it's from it's from AJ who asks Dear
John and Hank my friend and I were
wondering what would happen if you had a
body of water as big as a star and you
dipped the Sun into it would the energy
of the Sun just evaporate all the water
with the water put out the Sun we are
very curious Oh AJ I love this question
I love this question so much that I want
to call a plasma physicist and and be
sure that I'm going to give you the
right answer but I'm gonna give you my
guess I loved I Bob Wow okay
so if you had a ball of water a body of
water as big as a star that would be a
sphere of water in space and it
size of a star it probably would on its
own change dramatically before you were
able to get it to interact with the star
so the moment that this thing appeared
into existence it would crush down the
weight the density of the gravity
pulling all of those molecules of water
together might be I don't know that this
is definitely the case but might be
enough to to initiate fusion and that
ball of water that you are going to try
and put out the Sun with would become
its own star now I'm not certain that
this would happen because the you know
like there's a lot of oxygen in there
oxygen is much more difficult to fuse
than hydrogen there's also just it might
because of the density contract a great
deal when wind plasma began it might
also though I'd be interested to know
the density of the Sun I should have
looked that up but I haven't
it might also expand in size and
actually become a larger star than the
star you were trying to quench their
says this is the marvelous nature of the
universe that a ball of water the size
of the Sun is not going to be a ball of
water for long it is going to undergo
some some magnificent and and truly
substantial changes you know egg
sometimes I think like but then if you
did dip the Sun into that ball of plasma
it would just become a much bigger star
to get hit or make sometimes I find your
genuine enthusiasm about science
actually infectious like like I start to
glimpse how great teachers get students
excited about science like you seem to
genuinely love that question
[Laughter]
whereas I only asked it because I wanted
I wanted to make some jokes about taking
the Sun to the beach like I you know
like I took the Sun to the beach but oh
my the sunburn
yeah yeah I see I see what you take you
take bring it to a body of water and
you're just like hey I like it on the
beach do you as well a giant ball of
plasma oh man all right John we got a
question from Collette this is a this is
definitely an opportunity for some
dubious advice remember our advice is
dubious
she asks dear Hank and John my older
sister is currently dealing with
depression and has left high school the
same high school that I attend it's been
hard for me to understand what she's
going through so I haven't told anyone
people at school sometimes ask me why
she isn't at school or if she's coming
back I'm not really ready to start
telling people about what has happened
so I don't know what to say what do you
do when someone asks you a question that
you aren't ready to answer yeah I mean
this is a tough one
not least because when you say the truth
it only makes people ask more questions
right because the truth is I'm not ready
to talk about it or it's a family matter
or its private or you know it's more I
want her to be able to talk about it
right I don't feel like I should be
talking in her place and all of those
answers are only going to make people
gossip and and chitter and chatter and
and that's difficult I mean I you know I
I took a semester off from college
partly because I had whooping cough but
partly because of mental health problems
I suspect that if I hadn't had whooping
cough I still would have had to take the
semester off and and when people ask me
why you know later I was able to talk
about it but you know that's a that's
that's direct experience versus you know
a siblings experience if people had
asked Hank while I was taking a semester
off from school you know it's not really
my place Thanks place to answer you know
and I mean maybe that's maybe that's
something that you can say is just like
I don't I don't feel like it's my place
to talk about it you know I love my
sister and she's you know getting
getting what yeah getting what she needs
I don't know that stuff it might also be
something that'd be good to talk to your
parents about because obviously they're
more familiar with the situation than
people at school then you know anybody
hopefully anybody else in the situation
aside from your sister and and also
asking your parents it would be a good
idea to talk to your sister about it the
you know it might not be it might just
be adding stress to this already very
unpleasant situation but yeah I think
that I think that there is no good
answer
and when you when you in the problem
being that telling the truth in this
situation which is the thing that you
kind of have to do is going to create a
little bit of drama it's going to make
people feel a little bit uncomfortable
and and yeah people are gonna people are
gonna probably are gonna guess now I
don't know how supportive your friend
group is at school I don't know how how
for support or support of her friend
group is at school but yeah that it's
for my memories of school it's always
difficult to to deal with stuff because
people are you know people are all
dealing with difficult things but but
and they are not always kind yeah I mean
I think that that's one of the issues is
that you you know if you can count on
your friends to be kind and discreet
then that's one thing but a lot of times
you can't I know certainly for for large
swathes of my school life I couldn't and
and that that makes everything harder so
we're sorry I'm sorry that you're going
through that we're sorry that your
sister is going through that and and it
is tough to hold on to it can be tough
to hold on to those secrets and deal
with with those those family struggles
as far as empathizing with people with
depression I mean I think that's a
that's a huge challenge I have to be
honest with you like I I don't I don't
feel like people empathize particularly
well or even like it's possible to
empathize particularly well because
because depression is so specific and
interior I think that it's really really
hard to it's really hard to empathize
with and in general I think it's hard to
empathize with people's pain
there's a great observation in this book
that I was given by Mike Rugnetta called
the body in pain by Elaine Scarry I
think her name is and she says to be in
pain is to have certainty to hear of
others pain is to have doubt like your
own pain nothing is more certain than
your own pain but other people's pain is
kind of inherently dubious right because
like you don't know what they're really
going through you don't know how it
hurts or whether it hurts or where it
hurts really and is it's just incredibly
difficult to bridge that that empathy
gap and I think like it's even difficult
in art art is one of the places where
people connect the the most in terms of
you know finding ways into empathy and
even in art I think it's difficult god
this is a funny comedy podcast I mean I
just we just kill it
alright John I have what I think is an
important question that I want to get to
it's from Emma who asks dear Hank and
John in the last episode of the podcast
a listener not the last one but in a
previous episode a listener wondered if
there was anything in the world that
wouldn't lead to widespread death and
John replied yeah Purell but in biology
class that I had years ago we learned
that overuse of hand sanitizers could in
fact be working against us if hand
sanitizers killed 99.99% of all bacteria
that 0.1 percent that survived would
have some genetic property that helped
it live on and would pass that immunity
on down the generations until it evolved
an antibiotic resistant superbugs so no
hand sanitizers in the world would be
able to combat live ellipta you get the
idea so in the end couldn't Purell lead
to our widespread death after all sorry
John
no I have wonderful news which is that
Purell does not work the way that like
antibiotic soaps work yes so the point
oh one percent of bacteria it doesn't
kill it doesn't kill because it doesn't
touch and the way that alcohol-based
hand sanitizers work is different from
the way that other like antibiotics work
and while it is possible that someday I
guess bacteria could develop resistance
to alcohol they have not shown a great
resistance a great ability to do it over
the millennia so yeah it's good yeah
yeah it's it's it's based on how alcohol
affects bacteria the the physical way
that it affects them it's impossible for
bacteria to develop a resistance it
affects them physically it's not most
most like antibiotics that you take or
the antibiotics and antibacterial soap
work in various chemical ways but this
is a physical reaction it's basically
the same thing as boiling them or
heating them up a lot the it actually
causes their cell membranes to rupture
and that is a that's the thing that
happens and that's why if you get
alcohol and in a wound that hurts very
bad because it's doing the same thing to
your cells and it will do that to any
cell on earth unless a bacteria evolved
like a cell wall and then it would not
be a bacteria anymore
speaking of which Hank we should point
out that several listeners have written
in to say that Purell does cause
widespread death of course it causes the
extremely widespread death of bacteria
wow that is a great point John it's just
it's absolutely terrible for them and
and seemingly in a way that they have no
defense against no never and never will
which is excellent news because I am in
favor of the widespread death of
infectious bacteria I guess I am too
yeah I mean I just I find infectious
bacteria to be one of the least likeable
organisms my all-time top ten least
favorite organs yeah I mean there is
their sexiest bacteria the damage there
is some complexity here in that some of
the bacteria that cause disease also are
part of of healthy balanced microbiomes
as long as they don't get out of balance
or as long as they're in the right place
in your body so there is complexity you
don't want all of infectious bacteria to
to not exist you know e.coli exists in
our in our guts all the time and e-coli
causes disease but also is just a normal
thing to have in your body
I also I also have another update we've
had a lot of updates but but I I feel
like I need to get to this one because
it's been a few episodes now and I feel
bad about it a few episodes back someone
asked if if there were earth eclipses on
the moon and and I didn't i wass 'old on
that and I wasn't sure and I should have
just said what is the obvious truth is
that yes obviously it does happen there
are eclipses on the moon all the time
they are what we call a lunar eclipse
some people said that that happens every
new moon but that is not in fact what's
happening during a new moon that's just
when the side of the Moon that's being
lit up is facing away from us but when
when a lunar eclipse happens that is
when the shadow of the earth passes over
the moon and during that time if you
were on the moon you would be seeing the
earth come between you and the Sun and
the earth would be blocking out the Sun
and that would be a Terran Eclipse I
guess and you would be getting you'd be
you'd be shaded by the the earth and
that happens like for to like more than
four times a year four to seven I think
so it happens all the time don't think I
just like to point out Hank is that when
that question came up I very confidently
said stated that indeed there are such
eclipses and then you were wiggly wobbly
wofully wofully and as usual I was right
on science and you're wibbly-wobbly did
nothing it accomplished nothing all all
your wibbly-wobbly accomplished is you
having to post this update and in six
weeks when you have to come back to the
podcast and say it turns out that you
shouldn't eat macaroni a year after it
is expired because some poor soul out
there got botulism because of your
extremely dubious advice I will again
look like the genius that I am Hank I am
in no great hurry to move on to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon but I am
afraid that we have reached the point in
the podcast when we must I think that is
correct
well I have only terrible news so
perhaps you should give me news oh no
I'm so sorry to hear that well I have
good news I think though of course as
with you know interplanetary science it
turns out to be complicated news and
maybe not news at all but basically
there's been a there's been a
a formation on Mars that's been studied
for four years now because it looks a
lot like the the kinds of formations
that we see around hot springs on earth
and this is probably an area that was
geologically active and that had hot
springs on Mars at one point and hot
springs of course are an excellent place
for life to exist there are multiple
different ways that that that life in
Hot Springs can get energy they can get
it from the heat of the water they can
get it from minerals in the water that
have that have themselves extracted in
one way or contain the heat from from
you know geothermal processes and you
can also of course just get it from the
Sun the so so these are very interesting
areas they were worth worthy of a lot of
study there are microscopic features on
some of the rocks in this location on
Mars that that look mean they call them
cauliflower-like so imagine a
cauliflower little tiny cauliflower is
all over these rocks and they've been
studying these and and have been trying
to find analogues of of these kinds of
formations that have formed on earth
through geologic processes and they
haven't found any but they do find at
hot springs that there are very similar
shaped rocks with shaped like crystals
that form that are formed by biological
life by banker organisms and and and the
fact that they they have seen these very
similar shaped rocks on Mars and near
Hot Springs and around Hot Springs on
earth and that we cannot find a geologic
way where those same similar structures
would be formed is very exciting as you
might imagine and has been as being
discussed very actively right now of
course there's really no way to tell for
sure unless we are able to bring a
sample back from Mars study that more
carefully in a laboratory or take a
person to Mars along with a laboratory
with which to study those samples but
it's very exciting and and sort of like
continues to point to the
you know what we often find in
interplanetary science and what we
continue to find as we look for we as we
look for and discover more exoplanets
that you know there's obviously
something very special and unique about
planet Earth and the life there and and
humans in particular but things turn out
to not be as rare as we think they
should be and that the possibility and
and the fact that there has been a mouse
we've seen flowing water on Mars and the
possibility that there was once life on
Mars could really be the kind of thing
that we are going to find out with in my
lifetime and that is extremely exciting
so what you're saying Hank is that there
is a small possibility that there are
living call the flowers on Mars there's
definitely a small possibility a very
very very small possibility that there
they're living kala flowers on that's
just incredibly exciting I don't I don't
blame you for having having gotten
excited over that news meanwhile on on
earth but to be clear when I say very
small I I mean I mean just just
astronomically them more zeroes than you
could have put in your brain yeah after
the decimal point kind of problem ya
know you just described to me Martian
cauliflower and it does III I guess my
main concern is that it doesn't sound
delicious but and I'm suspicious of any
food grown near a hot spring but I'm
excited to find out what develops I will
say that I am deeply concerned if there
is life on Mars that it it's just gonna
completely take over this podcast that's
my main concern I think that it would be
bad for our podcast if there were life
on Mars but but time will tell
meanwhile on earth life has evolved to
such an extent that there is a species
capable of knowing itself and fathoming
the universe that species is called homo
sapiens
it is so far as we know unique among
all the species that have ever lived in
the entire universe and that species is
capable of intense and profound
collaboration and one of the ways that
it collaborates one of the most
beautiful and interesting ways is
football and the species has evolved an
ability to not only play football in a
collaborative manner but also to own
football teams in a collaborative manner
as AFC Wimbledon has owned in equal
parts by all of its fans you Hank can
join the Dons Trust at AFC Wimbledon's
website you're gonna get there
eventually right you're gonna get there
you're gonna get to the news it's only
$35 a year and you can be an owner of
AFC Wimbledon just like I am you'll earn
the same percentage of the club that I
do I am getting to the news from AFC
Wimbledon it is not great a UH we played
Yeovil Town which is right down it seems
like it would I believe is a fictional
place I believe it's in middle-earth but
they do not leave town not a high in the
table John Yeovil Town they are not a
they are not high in the table they were
lower in the table but then they beat us
it was a 3-2 game in the end we led on
two separate occasions
but Yeovil came back from one nail down
came back from 2-1 down and then and
then won the game 3-2 this is bad for us
on many levels it's the kind of game
that were expected to win playing Yeovil
Town a fictional place at home you would
expect to win that game it puts us 10th
in the table
look we're 22 points clear of relegation
the main goal for this season is of
course to stay in the Football League
but we're now three points off the
playoffs so it's a definitely a
disappointing result not what we were
looking for but the arc of history is
long Hank and it bends toward Wimbledon
well and also you have a lot of time to
make up those three points right yeah
but I mean if you can't get three points
against Yeovil it's it's it's it's
there's there's some deeper concerns mm
yeah well you know there's also just you
know the universal dice sometimes four
seeds lose 216 seeds it happens that's
right no it's definitely true and I
think we've got a we've got to stay
hopeful I am you know I'm sort of
perpetually in a state of concern over
AFC Wimbledon I'm not the kind of person
who I don't know I oh I just I'm just
I'm a worrier Hank and like I can't help
but look at AFC Wimbledon's remaining
fixtures and feel you know for lack of a
better term deeply concerned we play our
next game against Bristol Rovers this
weekend that will have already happened
by the time this fitness podcast is
uploaded so people of the future I can
only hope that we have gotten a result
against fourth place Bristol Rovers but
the time will tell
yes that would be excellent you could
move them down in the rankings while
moving yourself up it's a big game it's
an important game everybody get excited
about the game and check on the results
of the game when you hear the podcast
ending as it is doing right now John
what did we learn today well Hank we
learned that you really try hard to care
about AFC Wimbledon but you just I'm
sorry did I step on your news was there
more was there more to come oh it's fine
we learned that we waste a lot of
plastic making DVD covers and we are an
inherently wasteful people on this earth
right now but also that due to the
nature of the manufacture of plastics
it's complicated and we learned that
Purell is different from antibiotic and
soap in ways that are very encouraging
to John that's true
and finally we learned that while the
world is not yet at a place where a cat
sleeping on your stomach is a is a
proper excuse for the tardiness of your
arrival at your your source of
employment eight it may one day nope hey
why are you late for work oh because an
animal that we chose to domesticate
several thousand years ago that weighs
about 12 pounds didn't want me to stand
up
yeah yeah it's never going to be an
acceptable excuse here at the
Indianapolis branch of dear Hank and
John yeah no I mean if a person said
that to me I would and and I believe
them now I'm not gonna you not allowed
to have this excuse every day but I
would be like I understand I absolutely
understand so and they're so comfortable
they look so comfy they just I mean if
anybody at the Indianapolis office is if
Dear John and Hank shows up with that
excuse they aren't just it isn't just an
unexcused absence they're fired oh wow
Wow yeah you're fought you're out all
right well we operate our of businesses
very differently it's good it's good to
have different ways of doing things to
see which way is more productive and in
which place people enjoy working more
and everybody can discuss which office
is best anyway Hank this podcast is
edited by the hard-working
underappreciated and overall brilliant
Nicholas Jenkins our theme music is by
gunnarolla we're laughing because we
screwed up so many times in this podcast
that the hard-working underappreciated
Nick Dickens yeah he has had to craft a
podcast from scratch using just like
previous incidences of our voices is
molding it from the raw clay thank you
crashing the waveform into kumea for
thanks to everybody for listening and as
we say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
[Music]